So there's a time in almost every
business where you're going to
need to scale beyond what you have
available to you resource wise.
And at this point, you have to reach
out to investors because otherwise,
it's sink or swim.
You won't be able to
get to that next level.
You won't be able to grow or
scale your business,
and sometimes without growth or
skill your business is in trouble.
So at that point,
you want to bring an investor in.
And in the case of one of my companies,
we had to bring an investor in because
we had to hire more people and we had
to scale up our technology production.
And that was a very lengthy and
involved process overall.
It took almost a year just to close
that first round of financing.